hey folks um a lot of new faces for me
here today so
i hope you hopefully get something
useful out of this talk
um like you mentioned we have
really grown a lot at tapad starting
from a
initial essentially prototype on amazon
to having our own data centers and a
couple different continents and
still on scala which is a fantastic
technology for us but the data pipeline
itself has really evolved over time
starting from that small kind of
monolithic solution and going to
something that's very distributed much
more reliable and just generally more
robust
so
that's what i'll talk about here today
as the intro said i'm totally early
engineer tapad been working on this for
a little while
and today we're going to talk about data
pipelines and this is a goldberg machine
that looks like most data pipelines
probably maybe a little bit more
organized
so hopefully we can bring a little bit
of clarity to that
so the general outline i'll give you a
brief intro to tap ad
we can almost skip that if you have a
good one already and why do we even
bother with the data pipeline what is a
data pipeline
data goes in one thing
changes around a little bit and then
goes out the other side and hopefully we
get something useful out of that
the data pipeline has evolved a lot it's
initially essentially a monolithic
component of the system and now it's
very distributed
and then we're going to actually trace
through that whole pipeline in one sort
of example which is a day in the life of
an analytics pixel
and then we'll very briefly go over some
things that is thinking about doing with
the data pipeline in the future
so tempa does cross-platform advertising
and analytics this means we process
billions of requests today
two to twenty billion requests is normal
we push terabytes of logs and we need to
process this in some sort of reasonable
manner this is obviously above the scale
of a single node system so how do we go
about doing it
a very important component of tapad
specifically is the cross platform
component
so
everybody is able to do real-time
bidding they're able to buy on digital
devices very easily
but having connections between those
devices
is
the entire basis of tabat's platform in
today's day and age
websites like huffington post new york
times they have 50 or more of their
viewership on mobile devices but that
means that there's also close to 50
coming from desktop laptop maybe an app
and a traditional platform all those
different devices are completely
different users and this of course uses
analytics quite a bit so what tap that
does is we look at
traffic patterns of the internet
primarily north america and we'll see
that these certain devices kind of look
like they have the same pattern so maybe
they're actually represented with the
same person
we have a whole system of rules that
will process these different signals
like an analytics tracking pixel and
we'll infer these connections
anonymously
so this is a very simple example of a
graph we have a person who has multiple
devices we figure out these edges
calculating these edges is a big part of
the data pipeline which we're going to
get into a little bit later
also it's accurate we test this against
a third party who is subjective
and so far works out and it's getting
better
so this is why we have a data pipeline
we need to build this graph somehow
data in comes from these pixels
bid requests which are opportunities to
show an ad somewhere
and then they all get turned into a kind
of generic signal that signal is
processed in the graph building
algorithm and we create these nodes and
edges where a node is a device and our
graph and an edge as a connection to
some other device
breaking things out into a data pipeline
also gives us a lot of sanity
we're able to look at data at all these
different steps along the pipeline when
it comes in the first component out of
the first component into the second and
so on and so this is easy to debug and
understand actually what's happening as
opposed to data entering this black box
and a bunch of things happen you don't
really know what's going on it comes out
the other end
so another standard way of making a
distributed system more reliable is just
being able to decouple components so we
have many different things here that can
scale out individually
so
the primary business of tap that is
doing this real-time bidding so it's
very very latency sensitive we will do
350 000 requests per second and the
average latency on those things once it
hits our systems it's going to be under
50 milliseconds around 30 milliseconds
can you step back
sure so the question was can we step
back and describe what the bidding
process is
so in real-time bidding essentially what
happens is
uh some kind of publishers site imagine
espn.com
somebody goes to that page there's going
to be an ad that pops up somewhere on
that page the way that ad gets placed in
the real-time video context is that a
signal goes to a system called a supply
side provider
they aggregate
these opportunities to show bids from
multiple publishers
websites apps games that sort of thing
and then they fan that request out to a
number of demand side platforms this is
the bitter
that request is the option to attempt to
show an ad
and so we'll look at that it will have
an ip address
maybe some sort of a cookie id or a
hardware id
um we'll augment that with some sort of
demographic data any other audience
segments that we may have and then we'll
put it into our decision engine which
basically is a representation of an
advertiser's targeting criteria they may
say something like i want to target
people in their 20s and 30s in
the midwest or something like that and
this is the amount of budget that i want
to spend over some period of time and so
in that
request cycle this is all happening at
real time you hit the page the request
goes to the supply side provider gets
forwarded to the bidder this is what
does we'll say yes we want to target
this person so we'll send a response
that says we're willing to show this
creative that this price goes into an
auction system and then if we win the ad
is displayed
does that help
so the signals that are coming in based
on these bid requests and other sort of
analytics pixels you can think about
like google analytics on a website it's
constantly sending these little requests
that say a user has visited a site you
know maybe they have looked at a pair of
jeans and they've bought the pair of
jeans we stitch all these things
together over time and you can prevent
presenting the view to the advertiser
hey look your users are checking out
clothes on their mobile device and then
you show them an ad and they'll click on
it but then they'll actually buy it on
this
some other device the laptop so by
creating that graph of devices we can
present the full picture of the
consumer's path to purchase
so
the bidding process uses the graph
database
but it's very latency sensitive so we
want to actually be able to build the
graph
not in the middle of this bidding
sequence
so essentially
we
will take the signal put it onto a queue
have some other thing pull it off eq and
then build the graph and in the bidding
system all we need to do is do a lookup
against a key value store called
aerospike which is very fast we already
have that graph information available
and oh so batch mode is actually the
secondary version of the graph building
historically we've done all this in real
time
and batch mode allows us to look at much
more historical data and we get
many more connections and more accurate
connections so
to both the numbers right now at any
given time the graph database has about
about a million devices in it and then
roughly a quarter billion edges
and that's all based on real-time graph
building the batch building mode
uh is a big hadoop job that runs over
any number of weeks worth of data and so
we end up with the same
devices that's always constant but we
have double the number of edges about
400 million plus and we're looking to
get that better and the accuracy also
increases slightly
okay so the the second reason why we're
using state pipeline insanity i alluded
this to before you know we have a lot of
data but we don't have an unlimited
budget so we need to do something about
this we need to know when is it okay to
drop data how long do we have to keep
the other data what's important what's
not
one of the most important things here is
having a very clear data retention
policy so when you get to the scale that
you have something like this it's very
likely that you have many people who are
trying to use the pipeline for different
things so you have a data science team
that is
eager to use
like 100 of the cluster the second we
double it in size well the data usage
also doubles so we need to be very clear
about which data is lasting for you know
one month three months a year and so on
which data is just going to be wiped at
any point in time
and then so after we process all these
different
analytics pixels or compression trackers
anything like that we'll process we'll
make aggregations and then store that in
vertica and then vertica is a
column-oriented database speak sql so
it's very easy for analysts to go and
there's types of sql and look at
terabytes worth of data
without having to know any programming
so decoupling components pretty standard
thing if you're trying to make a system
more robust the bitter which is very
latency sensitive again it's only doing
the bidding and then the only part it
has in the graph building pipeline now
is that it takes an incoming signal and
then emits it over to a queue and then
it completely forgets about it
once things enter that pipeline it's on
a coffee queue the data stream can split
and merge very easily so
the core the backbone of the data
pipeline for us is kafka i'll get into
that a little bit more later but the
nice thing about it is that it's
essentially just like giant log file
that's
reliable and the consumer will connect
to kafka and say give me back
item 123 which is essentially an
ordering
number and you can have multiple
consumers reading from that log file and
then you'd imagine this
getting very complex
but the point is that you can tap into
the data stream at any point and then
feed something else back in
so we talked about this before but the
multiple stages of the pipeline are some
system on the edge which has has its own
kind of standard logging it will often
spool something locally to disk and then
take that batched
spool file and send it to another system
which puts it on a capital broker and
then the consumer finally our long-term
storage is in hdfs
we'll get into these stages in more
detail later on
so here we have a brief overview of the
history of our data pipeline the dark
ages it was just one giant monolithic
application that did everything
did bidding in one process also built
the graph
pipeline
in one process
and obviously that doesn't work it
doesn't scale it's basically just the
quickest way to get up and running
so we did some basic software
engineering and we added some cues did
all this graph building work
asynchronously but it's still happening
in the same process this is all built in
scala we use jetty for our server
everything's on the jvm
but this wasn't enough it got us pretty
far but we realized that as we're
continuing to scale up getting to this
you know hundreds of thousands of
requests per second we can't continue to
have everything wrong process it makes
upgrading things very hard because you
have one giant application
so we added some inter-process
communication and now multiple servers
each of which are handling one specific
part of
the pipeline
and doing the minimum possible thing
that they can do before they pass some
message on to the next stage of the
pipeline
at this point we also introduce a lot of
batching batching is really fantastic it
will
do wonders for your throughput and it
doesn't need to be slow you can even
match up maybe let's say 100 requests
over a few milliseconds and then send
that out and you completely avoid the
overhead of setting up and tearing down
different connections
after we realized this worked pretty
well and we continued to grow to the
next step analytics was becoming a
bigger and bigger part of tapas business
we figured out that kafka is working
pretty well we settled on that as the
main queue of the system
and avro is the main sterilization
format
so
the dark ages we don't like to think
about them
and yeah it wasn't fast enough very
quickly this was probably months and
i'm going to skip all this already i
forgot i had these extra slides
one of the advantages of settling on
some standards like kafka and afro is
that actually supported used by other
people so we rolled our own batching and
killing system but that takes a lot of
engineering work to get right
someone has already done it with kafka
it's a great tool highly recommended
okay so going on a little bit more about
batching i think this is an important
part of the data pipeline because you
get so many incredible improvements
the main
the main thing is think about an
optimizing compiler
loop unrolling is one way of making code
run faster and that's instead of doing
one thing on one pass loop you do
end things
you can apply this to pretty much any
stage of the pipeline and you're just
going to get incredible speed ups so try
to do that everywhere that you possibly
can
so this happens inside of an application
as well as between different
applications they're both applicable
okay so cues are another wonderful thing
um but they can fail horribly and kind
of
talk catastrophically excuse me and
you're not gonna like it so
this uh little quote over here is
paraphrased but it's definitely happened
more than once
what happens is the q is this nice
elastic component in the system that
allows you to sort of absorb extra
influx of work and then catch up a
little bit later but if you're dealing
with an unbounded queue
the system will fail at some point
you're going to keep adding things into
that queue until you run out of memory
and the process goes down
or through any any other failures so you
need to do something about this how do
you take care of a queue
so first of all monitor
we use graphite very heavily and we're
constantly pushing metrics about
produced and consumed messages so at a
glance we have a number of dashboards
that will show you if consumers and
producers are processing things at
roughly the same time if those lines
start to diverge you know that one of
the two things is operating
faster or slower than the other and
you're going to head towards a failure
unless you do something
you can set up automatic alerts around
this as well
back pressure is another important thing
back pressure means that
you have a consumer which is able to
tell the producer hey i'm overloaded
slow it down a little bit
that's actually more complex than it may
sound because if a consumer a is telling
producer a to slow down
you have to consider what is producer a
even getting its information from maybe
it is getting fed by some other producer
it's called a prime which doesn't have
back pressure so that means the producer
if it's getting a signal from the
consumer to slow down a little bit any
side to start dropping data maybe
spooling data locally maybe you send an
alert to the ops team and have them spin
up some more consumers something like
that but the point is that you need to
think about it you need to enter
engineer back pressure into the system
so you can have control of this pipeline
so
buffering is is basically
the same thing it's okay
unlike the last slide it might have led
you to believe just know how much you're
buffering if you have a large queue or
an unbounded queue and under normal
circumstances it's not very long but it
has a large capacity what will happen is
if things get out of sync you'll start
putting so much information into that
queue that you run if you're using a
language like scala that has garbage
collection you're going to run into gc
pressure and you haven't really seen it
before because you've only been using a
small percentage of the cube once it
fills up all bracelets
so spooling is another way of dealing
with the cube that's starting to get
overloaded basically take stuff out of
memory
right at the desk deal with it later
that's all the spooling is
and that allows you to operate in what i
call degraded mode instead of a system
completely failing you will allow it to
operate while dropping a little bit of
data it's not 100 of what you wanted to
be or at least the system is continuing
to work
so
we'll go on that a little bit more
actually
there are a few different methodologies
in doing this one you just drop data all
together
two you can spool it to disk and replay
it
dropping from the front of the queue or
the back of the queue
might make a difference in your
application so in tap that's in
because it's a latency sensitive request
that is in front of the queue is by
definition the oldest so if we're
getting overloaded we drop everything
off the front of the queue because those
are the oldest requests and they're
probably scale anyway and by the time we
catch up we have some newer requests and
we can respond to them
okay so serialization is an important
part of
so what kind of different technologies
so the question was what type of
different queuing technologies did we
try out so we had our sort of home drone
version which was basically just a jetty
finagle
we used protocol buffers to serialize
his small batch files
you can write limited records very
easily
and then kafka had a pretty decent
amount of mind sharing at that point
so we tested that one first and pretty
extensively and it performed up to our
requirements so we just went
went right with that one there are other
options like
you know active mq rabbit mq things like
that we did not evaluate them because
kafka has a different model where it's
as simple as can possibly be it's really
just a log file that happens to be
distributed and replicated so there's
less things that could possibly go wrong
we didn't need to calculate any sort of
exactly once semantics for the queue
we just throw stuff on the queue each
consumer which reached in that queue is
responsible for understanding where it
is in the stream
that's the question
yes
i'm going to get into that right now the
question was why did we switch from
photograph to avro
we actually use both
yes
sure the question was how do we scale
out kafka we'll talk about that a little
bit more later i'll try to hold some one
of the questions to the end but
basically you set it up and you just
keep adding
nodes into the cluster
and it works with you
so how many folks who are familiar with
protocol buffers raising hands if you've
heard of it yeah so everyone's heard of
it and actually use it in production
still you know quite a lot of people
it's about a third
so
protocol buffers is a tried and true
serialization methodology and uses
tagged fields so what this means is that
in the actual binary representation of a
record
part one of the bytes is the field
number and then i'll have the type of
the field for example enter string and
that'll have the length of that and then
the actual value
so this means that a protocol buffer is
almost self-describing
i say almost because it doesn't actually
map names you need to have the schema
available so you know what your field
name is
but you can just look at this this
binary record and know
how many fields are in there what is the
value what is the type and so on
so you don't need to publish a schema
separately when you're just using this
for communication
so
you can evolve the schema
well actually let me take a step back
this part here is an example of what
a
how to define a record in protocol
buffers
this is the name of the class
you can have required optional and
repeated fields and each one of them has
a number whenever you change the schema
you will always increment this tag this
is how you can be forwarded backwards
if compatible
if i no longer want this
value here then i can just remove it if
i want to add something new i can say
for example
required
time stamp equals three and then now
that attack value is three and i can
deserialize in the future and just end
it
the reason i put this example up here is
because protobuf does not have a map
type so we just use a string pair and
since you can have a repeated field
basically have repeated tuples of keys
of values and that's pretty much the
same as a map
and just try to be careful and not
duplicate keys
and we're going to talk about avro next
i think that protocol buffers it's much
easier to evolve the schema because it
has this kind of self-describing type of
field method
so why do we switch to afro here's the
answer to the question
for
storage and hadoop we want to use avro
because it's inherently splittable so
when you're writing a mapreduce job on
hadoop your input files
are all going to go to some mapper that
mapper will read the file do some
processing and then emit some sort of
data
now if you have many different files you
can have one mapper close up one file
and so on but if you have one gigantic
record a file that could be let's just
say it's a couple of gigabytes
you want to have multiple nodes process
this file but if it's one file it needs
to know how do we split the thing up
avro has this built in every so often
you'll have a split marker and as you
look at the file you can figure out
what's an appropriate place to split it
small files are kind of the achilles
heel of hadoop because each mapper is
supposed to load a file so if you have
it's a cluster with
a thousand mappers and you have a
billion files each of which is just a
few bytes
this job will just never complete it's
going to be horrible but if you have the
same amount of data in one giant file
that you can then split to the number of
mappers things are going to move along
much more smoothly
so how is avro different well it does
not use this attack approach the user's
names will serialize everything
according to the order that you have
defined the name in the schema
this means that it always has to
serialize every field as opposed to
protocol buffers you can skip optional
fields it's fine because you have the
tag in there you can figure out which
one is which
so to do an optional field you use the
union type and you say this thing can be
either alone or novel and if it's null
it just doesn't take up very much space
okay so how do we actually evolve the
schema in navarro since we don't have
these attacks
well you basically need to be careful
that's kind of the catch there is a
defined way in which a schema evolves so
if you have written some file using your
old schema and you want to read that
back using a new schema the set of
resolution rules which will say
what should this field evaluate to given
my new schema it's a little bit tricky
and complicated and that's why we didn't
use it as a serialization in our key
value store we use it for hadoop and
kafka just because we use the same code
and it's political like i mentioned
before
so to deal with those schemas what we do
is actually store them in zookeeper a
schema is basically just a json
description of what fields and types and
default values you have
and
you can take a hash of that
store it in the header of a file and
then when your deserialization code
actually loads up the file you can look
at the header and say okay i have this
hash you know abc let me go to my schema
storage and zoom keeper figure out what
schema exists that has that hash i think
it's an md5 hash or shot one or
something and then so you load that
memory you deserialize the file
okay so that was kind of a high level
intro and now this is a day in the life
of a pixel this is a
thing that is happening billions of
times per day
and
we'll kind of go down this
this path these are the different
components in this particular system
we start off on the pixel server this is
just our name of it
it lives on the edge of the system
it doesn't do very much except send
information over here and respond with
that pixel
this guy will publish information to
kafka
consumer will pull from kafka
consumer will do some work and in many
cases it will ultimately log to hdfs
and then we have a bunch of jobs that
are running on the new cluster which
will read back this data and usually
generate more data or potentially insert
it into another database
okay so the pixel server is something
that's supposed to be very reliable if
we have a pixel
tracking pixel on the
front page of bank of america or
something like that
if the request goes out and doesn't come
back with a very fast response or comes
back to the broken response we get
kicked off the page very quickly
probably going to lose a contract or
something like that the customer will
not be happy so this pixel server just
accepts a request
serializes it
into a batch file and it just
immediately responds
with a 200 and a transparent pixel
this part happens asynchronously
actually it does write it to the file
system and then every so often that gets
picked up and sent back over to the
pixel ingress server
so these files are pretty small we
happen to have it set i think two
kilobyte max and then maybe a 10 second
max until this thing gets shipped
this code
used to be part of that monolithic stack
that i was mentioning earlier you just
took the same code base split it out and
we run it inside of its own cluster
this doesn't need to be nearly as
reliable as this because if something
crashes or is slow you can just restart
it or spin up some new servers in that
cluster
so we take this request these serialize
things some things that are very latency
sensitive like for example if a click
happens we want to make sure that it
gets back into the database really fast
this server will process it but
primarily this is just
a path to get data into kafka where it's
easy and standard to read from again
okay so now we're in kafka this is the
queuing system i was talking about
it has a number of nodes each of which
has a lot of storage about a terabyte
per server
and
the way that it works is you have some
configuration file that says these are
the
these are the topics that i want the
topic is essentially another name for a
queue you can say how many partitions
you want for that
and a partition is a piece of the queue
those are distributed and replicated you
have a master partition and a slave and
they'll be on multiple servers different
servers so if one goes down the other
one will pick up as master and you don't
lose data
if you've phenomenon's read the call me
maybe series you'll see that there are
some
even naked break but by and large for us
it's been extremely reliable
we have our retention set to be 24 hours
this means that if the data in a queue
is not processed by the end of that 24
hours it's gone however we'll just
believe it so we need to be careful and
monitor that we are actually keeping up
as we expect
one of the reasons why kafka is pretty
easy to use is because it uses zookeeper
for coordination so when the cluster
comes up the brokers which is kind of
the
middle component this thing is a
producer this is the broker and then the
consumer reaches on it
this will register itself with zookeeper
and when a consumer comes up you can
also connect to zookeeper which is not
drawn here so just make that light up
there and it'll automatically figure out
where it to read so you basically just
start it up give it an address zoom
keeper and you can start processing
and you can add different topics
dynamically which is kind of handy
so here are some code
examples this is scala and we have
developed a bunch of tooling behind the
consumers to make them easier to use
this trait defines a generic plugin some
of the code is a little bit modified but
this is essentially the right thing
any producer or consumer can register a
plug-in a plug-in is just a series of
callbacks
and then the code that drives these
producers and consumers will invoke
startup success failure shut down as
appropriate so startup and shutdown are
pretty obvious it's when the server
comes up or down on success and failure
is when each
entity or each message has been
processed
some examples of plug-ins we have our
graphite so
we'll make a
we'll say we received a click okay
increment that counter in graphite
batching log file playback
is fairly clear from the name i guess
you read back from file reprocess the
information
the timestamp driven clocks are pretty
neat so since we have multiple producers
and consumers all publishing to this
queue
the queue is split into multiple
partitions it's not as simple as having
just one producer one queue and one
consumer things can happen at different
times so your consumers can start to get
into a kind of
not quite an out of sync situation but
one could be further ahead than the
others and if you need to know all data
up to a certain point in time that means
you need to know how far each individual
consumer has processed so the way that
this works
is that we connect to
zookeeper
and every time
well it's sampled but essentially every
time that we
finish processing a message
we'll update the time stamp in zookeeper
and then when we read we'll just read
any number of clocks or timestamps that
are inside that cluster for that
consumer then you take the min and you
know that's how much data has been
reliably processed
so here's a little bit more code this is
essentially how the plugin gets
registered
in the boot class we call register
plug-in on the consumer
pass in for example the graphite plug-in
the playback plug-in clock plug-in it
adds it to this list
and then later it will be invoked
something like this so we have
this code which contains a success
result
is quite a bit deleted from here but so
the key component is that
you have a list of plugins and for each
one you invoke this particular callback
this is just an example of the success
one but it does the same thing for a
failure if this is a failure type or a
retry something like that
okay so some more code
we have a batching retry plugin which
will say if you've failed processing how
many times do you want to retry
processing that exact same message
before you give up and go on
and then the back off is in milliseconds
we'll do an exponential back off which
you can see here
because when you're dealing with this
much data maybe you have something
that's just serialized in a weird way or
for some reason it's failing splitting
exception you don't want that to stop
the entire system because probably
there's just a few bad things and you
want to continue moving
but if it continues to fail then there
actually is a problem you want the
system to stop or alert someone and not
continue to process that data
so what the retry
logic does here is once you instantiate
um an instance of this with maximum
attempts and back off it will try to
succeed or will try to process this many
times every time it fails
it will retry
but a little bit more slowly than before
okay so now we've just gotten past the
consumer part it's doing batching it
will handle a few different errors
and then if errors continue to
accumulate then it will actually stop
and then you need to intervene but
generally speaking there'll be an error
here and there it's not that big of a
deal we'll log it look at it later
and after all these consumers have
finished processing they're normally
going to take that bit of information
and log into hdfs which is our
quote-unquote permanent storage it's in
quotes because it's not really permanent
they'll have a different retention
policy depending on the type of data so
some logs we might want to keep for a
year some for 60 days 30 days
things that we
want to delete we can move into amazon
glacier because it's fairly cheap and
we're probably never going to read it
again but we don't necessarily want to
lose it
once we get uh actually take a step back
this part here when you go from pixel
ingress to kafka we're switching from
uh protobuf serialized
records
over here to avro and the reason for
that is well here we just started using
vertical buffers and it works great so
we haven't had to touch that code for
ages
but once we're over here
there is very similar code often that
runs in the consumer as in our various
jobs on hadoop so you can just use the
same code that operates on the same type
of serialized data without having to
rewrite things
and once we log into hdfs
things are already in approve so the
consumer can match up individual
requests write one large file to hdfs
and then the hadoop job will read that
file split it appropriately and then do
whatever processing it's supposed to do
can't emphasize this enough
the more storage you have the more will
be used
okay so
what are these hadoop jobs well the
hadoop cluster is on 2.0
which is yarn and this is essentially a
resource manager
and your resources are some storage you
have some compute capacity this is
essentially the operating system for a
loop cluster
you have
file system hdfs that is this
distributed file storage i think our
cluster hit a petabyte not too long ago
and it's kind of still chugging so
that's good
and you can submit a job to this cluster
and the job will say you know i need
this many
cores i need this much memory and so on
and yarn will say okay great i know
about these nodes over here you can run
your job on that
so some common things we'll do actually
is rewriting outprofiles as part k we'll
get into that more later
installing is the tool that we use to
write the mapreduce jobs
scalding is a scala api for cascading
cascading is an api that allows you to
easily write mapreduce jobs without
having to use the low-level
java classes
you have some
code for this actually
yeah so this is what scalding looks like
this is an example i just
took right from their documentation
but it really is this simple you have a
big job
which gives you the access to some
arguments these are just command line
arguments basically and you write code
as though you're just working with the
collections library you have a list of
things you want to transform them or
filter them in some way so in this case
we have a text file
with many lines we break that line apart
into individual words and so now instead
of essentially having a list of lines we
have a list of words
and the field name is called word
and then we'll do a group by and this is
just like sql you do a group by this is
like doing a count
and then ultimately you write the output
and the output will be
every distinct word along with how many
times it appeared at the input
so this one's really simple but
if you were to write this in the
low-level api in java it would just be
really painful and a lot of code and
here it's much more clean
it also gives you facilities to do
join and
actually there's
join with large joining the small jordan
is tiny and joined with tiny is the
greatest thing well has anyone here used
scalding any chance
anyone used join with tiny method
and so i just i learned this one not too
long ago
and uh basically it took a job that was
taking
a couple days to run had a very big
joint i realized actually that the one
table to join against was really small
fit in memory
change it to use join with tiny and the
whole thing completed probably 30
minutes or so
okay i'm going to
go back a little bit here
uh to rewriting avro files is part k so
we'll talk about ever a little bit so
what is parquet parque is a sort of meta
format that can sit on top of another
serialization format and it's column
oriented and the reason why this is
fantastic the column-oriented aspect of
it is that most of the time if you have
a bunch of data written down these
records have let's say any number of
fields you want to write a job that only
needs to look at one or two of the
fields why bother reading and
deserializing all the other fields well
if you're doing a row-oriented
approach you just can't get around it
but parquet splits things up so it's
much much faster
as one example we have a job that has to
produce
this is the graph building pipeline
where the individual records have a lot
of data we only need to look at two
fields so we can reduce the amount of
bytes read by
upwards of 90
so that of course is going to make the
job run significantly faster
sorry uzi is a job scheduler
again a little more later but
essentially we'll have a number of
different jobs that are supposed to kick
off at a specific time based on some
specific criteria for example the
existence of a certain input and lucy
will schedule that for us
so photo credit to hortonworks this is
yarn
um okay so a little bit more on parquet
the column-oriented aspect allows us to
do uh the push down projections
and that's where we say for any given
input
so we have these bid requests for
example
we create a projection
of the same type
and then over here we'll say what field
do we actually want the dot indicates a
nested field which is really handy
because
rich data is going to be nested so you
might as well deal with it
as opposed to trying to avoid it
so here we're saying that in this field
of the record the request record there's
a sub field called query params and we
want to read that
and also the top level we have a partner
id which we want to read
so invoke read
sampling just allows us to look at less
data than we otherwise would and we do a
map too
so this request represents
this class
and we're going from one giant request
to just a tuple of two items here
and so the request
here this class
oh i forgot to change the name
anyway this class is code that's
generated by avrom
and so we call request.getheader we get
back this part and then get choreograms
we get this
if we
were to do something else so for example
request.getheader.gettimestamp
this would throw a null pointer
exception because we explicitly told rk
we don't care to load that so you need
to be sure that you're actually
requesting the data that you're going to
use down here
and the other thing i wanted to touch on
was predicates
so with parquet you can use predicates
to actually
filter
based on some
some sort of native type so if you have
a timestamp field for example
and you only want to load
let's say the most recent data but you
just have this giant file that has a
couple weeks worth of data for some
reason
you can have what's called a push down
predicate which will evaluate at the
point where you're actually just
starting to read that file so you can
say if timestamp is greater than
some value then read otherwise don't
read
and i don't have a good example for that
right now but this has a similar
benefit as projections which is that you
are reading significantly less data than
you otherwise would need to
it just takes that application logic and
pushes it down a lower level so you skip
the read and the parsing
okay this is probably the worst slide i
don't know if this is very easy to see
but
it's an example of how we use busy uzi
is a workflow coordinator what does that
mean
it's a directed acyclic graph of actions
so the action
that's going to get kicked off at some
point is maybe report some data from
some data store
if that completes successfully then you
go to the next step which is to process
some job that completes successfully
then you go to the next thing which is
another post-processing or maybe export
to a database
when you configure the whole thing in a
bunch of xml
it's a little bit clunky
but so far it's been
it's been working for us
okay so this pixel that we've been
following down the path has finally made
it into hdfs there's some new jobs that
are rereading it producing aggregates
and what will happen very frequently is
that we want to take that aggregate and
put it into vertigo
i mentioned vertigo a little bit earlier
but because you can talk to vertical sql
it makes the data accessible for
anyone who's not a programmer basically
if you know how to do select field from
table then you can get access to it
so this will happen with
just about all the data that's streaming
through our cluster
okay so i wanted to throw this stack
summary up here because one of the
really interesting things about the data
pipeline is that it's taking all these
distinct components putting them
together in this beautiful orchestra of
technology and you know when you look at
zoom keeper it's really easy to start
you just install it you have to run a
start script that's great but then it
needs to connect to kafka somehow and
then that thing needs to connect to a
consumer and a producer and all this is
running and a little bit of mayhem
but these are all things we use scala is
the primary programming language we'll
use jetty or denny as the underlying
server
finagle i didn't talk about before but
sort of a nice layer on top of
on top of these
for making that http or actually any
sort of server and client
serialization
these are all great parkay works with
avrom so you're actually using the same
classes under the hood it's just that
now it's organized in a different
physical way
so we'll usually write things to disk in
hdfs with avro and then after a little
while we'll go back and reprocess it in
parque and the reason why we wait for a
little bit is because we need to have a
big enough batch of avro data in order
to make it worthwhile to write into this
column oriented format
there are row groups in part k so
you sort of have this cluster of records
that is kind of like a row uh even
though they're stored individually as
columns on this
nobody need the batch in order for that
to be useful
got what we talked about jack jack
yeah
scoop we didn't talk about it all this
is a library that allows basically jdbc
for
hadoop it will allow you to read and
write from a database that has a jdbc
connection so we'll use this as the
final step of the data transformation
process to put an aggregate into one of
these tables
so for next steps we want to
look at alternatives for boozy because
like i mentioned before
it's fine with what it does but it's a
little bit clunky you need to write
these properties files we have these
scripts that will generate some xml and
then upload it into the cluster and so
on i know there's alternatives out there
we just haven't really committed any
time to evaluating them yet so
hopefully they'll come up in the road
map sooner rather than later
and then
we want to look at hive velmont hive is
sql on top of hadoop and the reason for
this is again to make the data in hdfs
accessible to non-developers it's a lot
of people who know how to write sql
they can't get into the data in hdfs
unless they know
how to program and scalding right now
so by
setting up
we'll make that data accessible to them
impala is a similar sort of thing
basically
as hive so we'll just evaluate two of
them see what's better and faster
and the difference is that hive
essentially puts a table structure on
top of your data and then you can write
sql to access the data and impala will
sort of create some projections so you
can actually scan things faster
druid is a
real-time big data analytics database
we essentially have our own in-house
version of this that's the whole
pipeline which receives many many many
distinct requests
and then batches them up into some
aggregates and
at the expense of storage
you have much faster query times because
you can look at an aggregate over a day
and see two billion things happen in one
request as opposed to doing a table scan
counting individual rows apollo i'm
sorry we'll do that for you
and that's all i have right now
thanks so much for your time
yes
so the question was
we looked at other polymer storage
projects basically and other
replacements for uzi
so park a works pretty well
i haven't looked at the other ones very
deeply
this integrates
very well with our ecosystem already and
there's a bunch of tools that support it
so it's worked out very well for us and
it's also a project that is very active
and it's moving forward so the ability
to write those push down predicates
is getting implemented in all the
ecosystem so that's that's very nice
there
for uzi
you mentioned luigi and we've looked at
luigi read some blog posts about it
it sounds great it sounds simple it
seems like everyone has their own
version of something like uzi the fact
is we just haven't quite had the time to
evaluate other options yet so we'll get
around at some point and replace it or
maybe write our own i think facebook has
something called data swarm luigi i
think is out of yahoo maybe um
that's down here oh great there we go
let's talk
later
yeah you can push me on
the question was how do we come up with
the data retention policy and then how
do we communicate that the data
retention policy is primarily a people
problem it's not a tech problem
the only aspect of the tech problem is
that at some point you're going to run
out of space then you run out of space
what do you do what do you delete first
so
recently just called a couple meetings
with people who are using the data most
heavily and said okay here is the growth
rate of this data we know that we're
getting x number of requests per day
each one is this size we know that we're
going to at this rate run out of storage
in a week
do you really need a year's worth of
data
oftentimes the answer is just no you can
come to some kind of agreement about
that
it's just a matter of knowing what your
your input rate is basically and then
how far back every individual needs or
every individual group needs for that
data
and
sometimes you have to fight a little bit
hard for
keeping a shorter policy because
sometimes we ask people well do you want
a little bit or do you want it all let's
say well of course i want it all without
fully understanding the cost in storage
both in dollars and compute time and so
on so
just uh back into the calculations and
then working with individual
stakeholders to figure out what's
reasonable
and sticking to the guns and making that
document published where everyone knows
what's going on
yes do you use the avro trendy format at
all
that's the columnar version
the question was do we use avro's uh
culinary version uh the answer is no i'm
actually not familiar with that one okay
um
i mean this
a very is question but
where do you get your data are you
getting it from individual websites or
are you calling me from isps like
you know comcast
sure the question is where does the data
come from it's from individual sites so
for example if you
you take your browser and you go to some
web page that has a an analytics pixel
on it
the pixel is just like html img source
equals whatever and that tells the
browser make an http request over to
this server
so it's going directly from the user's
browser
over the you know internet tubes over to
our server we'll take that information
and just serialize it into proto or afro
or something like that but this happens
a lot and that's where all the data
comes from wouldn't it help your cause
if you've had access to the isp
you can identify
that individual user's history
throughout the day
because you know when you're
yeah so the comment was wouldn't it be
nice to work with isps and get a
more accurate history of browsing data
so that that may be the case but
we're trying to do all this in an
extremely privacy conscious way so tap
is by far the most privacy conscious
advertising company out there we build
up the edges anonymously and we will
very actively and proactively remove
extra data that we don't like that is
not essential for building a graph
pipeline so any sort of personally
identifiable information for example
login info if you're logged into
facebook facebook knows exactly who you
are we don't want that data we never
look at it we'll only use something like
that via an objective third party to
test our probabilistic algorithm for
graph building
uh two questions the consumer part of
your pipeline are the plugins
is there are they independent or is
there
the question was essentially are the
plugins and the consumers
are they independent or can you use them
together
so you use them together when you
instantiate either a producer or a
consumer you'll call
you know
client.register plugin and then you give
it the
whatever plugin you have
and it just adds that onto a list
internally for that consumer and when
the callback happens
in order of registration callback will
be invoked in a chain so
you can do some tricks to maintain
states the consumer itself is capable of
maintaining its internal states and so
the plugin could do something like that
but we try to keep things as pure as
possible just because it makes things
easier to conceptualize and reason about
so the plugins will generally just do
kind of one thing which is probably
maybe doing some internal batching and
so the plug-in maintains its own state
that is not modifiable by another
plug-in
or we'll just send a request to some
kind of third-party thing like graphite
for example to log that a metric has
happened
second question is when you build the
graphs do you actually take snapshots of
the graphs or
do you just keep the most up-to-date
version
the question was after the graphic
building process has produced a graph do
we take snapshots of it or do we just
have this living thing in memory that's
a great question we do take snapshots of
this every single week and we store that
in hadoop and
the reason is is uh twofold actually one
we just want to have a backup in general
so if the data somehow goes away we wipe
out our aerospace cluster we can replay
the data back and we're going to be okay
the other thing is that
the key value store which is
our graph database
is right in the middle of the bidding
sequence and needs to be really really
fast if we want to do analytics we can
do a scan on that database which
basically means give me every key and
every value but that puts a lot of load
on the system and it's going to make
anything else relying on that database
more slow so by taking the snapshot
throwing it into loop you can do batch
offline processing without impacting
that flow
we're also able to do the batch building
in uh graph mode i'm sorry
graph building in batch mode and we'll
we can take signals from anywhere
including the snapshot
and compare against those things run
analytics on the version that is the
snapshot so
the
snapshot is the best word of the
real-time sort of ever-changing graph is
version one over here and then we have
version two which is a batch build
process we can see which one actually
worked better
so snapshots are essential it's one of
the key things when when uzi notices
that a snapshot is complete then you
have dozens of other jobs kick off and
start reading through that data to
provide analytics to our customers
a little bit more about how we produce
the graph and store it
basically
so part of that is the secret sauce so
you can come and work at that time
you'll know everything but
the other thing is basically
we'll look at co-occurrences of devices
on networks and a look at
anonymized browsing history of different
devices that are tied to some sort of
identifier and so we see this this pair
of devices
together at some point
and we'll store a bit of history about
that and we see the same pair of devices
again and again and again the more often
we see this basically more likely it is
that these two devices are
representative of the same user
there's a bunch of heuristics in here
which will say how long is too long to
associate those devices
what sort of network information is
actually valid
if you have a billion devices coming off
one network it's
not really giving you any useful
information but
the real-time process is taking a
sighting of a device storing it
somewhere in
short-term storage when another one
comes by you look that up do some
comparisons to check the timestamp see
if they look similar and if they do look
simple enough we'll create or strengthen
an edge the patch building process is a
little more complicated because you can
look back for a lot of data whereas the
real-time building one is
it's really just keeping about you know
a week or so is worth of data
and so that's stored in aerospike
the sort of living device graph it's a
distributed
key value store it's pretty fast so
we're doing
we're definitely over 350 reads per
second and then about a tenth of that
for um for rights per second
and 99th percentile latency for that for
reads is a millisecond and for writes
about two milliseconds and so it's handy
because it's much easier to scale a key
value store than a relational database
so as soon as the graph gets bigger we
add another node into the cluster
yeah so 350 transactions per second on
our respect for reads per second in this
case
it probably spikes higher something like
that for 1 000 because we're doing
at peak time about 350 requests per
second on the bidder
and then that may
cause additional lookups not necessarily
one could be two would be three
so the reads are higher it's a good
database
yeah so the question was how do we test
the accuracy of the graph
after we've built up the graph
over time we have these
series of nodes and edges and we have a
third party who has
basically a similar set of data but it's
based on
some sort of validated set of logged in
users who are opting in to
be identified on multiple devices
but you can essentially think about it
like if facebook has you logged in on
your phone and on your laptop browser
and then they know that those two
devices are the same so we'll go through
our list of edges
take a sampling
send them over to this third party and
say we think devices one and two are the
same person and then we'll get back to
yes or no
and we do this pretty often every week
and the accuracy is staying 85 or higher
the question was is it hard to compete
with a company like facebook that has
this truth data to begin with
so
yes in a sense we're competitors but our
approach is is very specific
specifically to derive this information
anonymously we never want to deal with
that logged in information because we're
working with a fortune 500 company
they're privacy conscious they don't
want to be caught up in some sort of
scandal where
so for example google got slapped on the
wrist a while ago if we're doing some
like overly intrusive tracking
so we just punch all that and say look
privacy is really important
let's make sure that we're doing it
without any personally identifiable
information
okay less last one
sure the question was
talk a little bit about ad hoc analytics
so we have a lot of ad hoc analytics and
usually what will happen is um
maybe a customer will will contact our
account manager and say
how's my campaign doing it looks like
people are not buying enough widgets
what's going on and so we'll look at
some standard key metrics for example in
graph lights and different logs and
ultimately it'll come down to writing a
sculpting job that will analyze uh
different inputs so um any individual
engineer will do something like this and
we have a git repository that contains
all these different jobs and so you go
up there fire up your editor
and write something that usually will
join a couple data sets so you have an
incoming bid request stream over here
then you have a
set of ids from the customer sent over
and they want to say they want to know
how often do we see these devices as
represented by a set of ids in the
actual supply so we can estimate scale
scale just means how many apps are we
able to show how many times are we able
to reach these users and so then you can
actually give them an answer so that
that's one um
reports come up all the time which is
one of the reasons why having something
like hive would be nice just a little
bit faster the analytics team and the
yield team can just do it on their own
program
okay thank you